la convention citoyenne qui nous a réuni
c'est un exercice de démocratie
participative qui permet de redonner la
parole aux citoyens dans le souci
d'enrichir le débat public améliorer la
qualité la légitimité des décisions et
ce afin de mieux répondre aux attentes
de la population donc pour accomplir ces
travaux et comprendre les enjeux qui en
sont liés nous avons rencontré un nombre
important de spécialistes du sujet
environ une soixantaine ce qui nous a
permis ensuite de débattre de manière
éclairée
le dialogue a permis d'esquisser des
perspectives des propositions communes
en prenant en compte le vécu et les
différentes sensibilités exprimées au
sein de la société française ces travaux
menés dans le cadre de la convention
citoyenne peuvent éclairer les pouvoirs
publics et nourrir la législation future
donc les citoyens ont répondu à 97% que
le cadre d'accompagnement de la fin de
vie doit être améliorée et à 82% qu'il
n'est pas adapté aux différentes
situations rencontrées la conviction
commune est de renforcer d'améliorer
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie car à
ce jour on constate une inégalité
d'accès et une absence de réponse
satisfaisante pour certaines situations
de fin de vie
plusieurs propositions collectives ont
été adoptées à plus de 80%. le respect
du choix et de la volonté du patient
l'information grand public le
renforcement de la formation des
professionnels de santé
garantir les budgets nécessaires et
l'accompagnement de la fin de vie
développer l'accompagnement à domicile
garantir un accès aux soins palliatifs
pour tous et sur l'ensemble du
territoire assuré une égalité d'accès et
améliorer l'organisation du parcours de
soins de la fin de vie
cette réflexion commune
issue de la démocratie participative a
mis en exergue la nécessité de
développer la culture palliative et les
soins palliatifs dans une société plus
solidaire tout en octroyant des droits à
ceux qui le demandent concernant leur
fin de vie notre travail à vocation à
alimenter la réflexion des pouvoirs
publics en esquissant des propositions
qui pourraient peut-être être le modèle
français de l'aide active à mourir